for better or worse worse or like it or
not I mean you and I are very different
individuals we are maybe extremely
different and somehow we have been put
together by divine mother for this
journey that has ignited some
inspiration some vision for you know for
many who you know write to us who want
to know how we are in relationship and
the fact that we are so extreme that you
know sort of everything about the way we
walk the earth is completely different
the way we approach the earth the way we
experience life and I'm looking for now
this next level of evolution and
expansion when we are truly igniting
both feminine and masculine energies
within ourselves and as we access these
greater energies of fully stepping into
our power how does that look in a new
paradigm relationship and so we have
traces and aspects of this
prince/princess paradigm that we you
know we've that we've played into that
have worked for us and it is a human way
of relating man and wife and I feel like
we are on the precipice of writing a new
way of being relate in relationship and
and what does that mean and so for me to
be clear because I can see you're like
you're like can you make a list can you
no I'm not but I do want ya flush that
out so I know exactly what I mean I'm
looking for first of all more ceremony
in our marriage I'm look but I'm looking
for it not in not in that I'm doing it
and you're going along with it I'm
looking for a recognition and a knowing
of the power of ritual and ceremony and
as we move through life the letting go
of our habits of watching Netflix of
watching you know movies whatever those
humanly activities are that that gather
our attention for a moment
I'm looking for an expansion into really
understanding that a life is precious
and every moment we spend is precious
and now that we know that we've been
given the privilege of being in this
space of having an audience of having
people that we can commune with really
committing to using that time and using
that time in relationship so we're back
to the anniversary no date no
celebration the reason why I wasn't
really attached to it is I didn't want
to go to dinner with you I don't want to
go to a movie with you I don't want to
go do some typical anniversary
esque you know I don't want a dozen
roses from you I want to go on the side
of a cliff and like take our clothes off
and you know right as you know light a
ceremonial fire not really because their
fires around here but you know what I'm
saying I mean I want to explore what can
we really do together that's beyond I've
gone to enough dinners
I've had enough roses I don't need to go
to another dinner I don't need to go to
we can't even go to hotel room because
you sleep in a tent so unless we bring
the tent to the hotel I know I get what
you're saying so do you okay yeah and I
and I'm I'm up for that
you know I'm up for that new experience
and I think it would it would cultivate
a an enhanced level of intimacy that
would take us into this next chapter and
I I think just doing a retrospective on
on you know where we're at and how we
got here I look at it like this we we
got together for whatever reason to
co-create we committed to this path less
trodden we underwent difficulties we
burned in the fire almost died to to
emerge from that and then we're
presented with opportunities that I
think over the last seven years whatever
it is eight years I have just worked my
ass off to capitalize on in order to
create stability for the family and also
almost as in amends for the trauma that
preceded it and approved to myself that
I could be a successful productive
member of society which is something I
have previously struggled with my entire
life or at least beginning when I
started started drinking and I've been
in kind of crisis mode for that entire
eight-year period just trying to make it
work and now we've emerged from that
with a situation that is successful it's
stable I've got this platform I'm able
to provide for the family and
essentially I'm in this incredibly
privileged rare situation where I get to
make choices about where I want to place
my energy and make money like I am
essentially in control of that but I'm
still operating day to day like I'm in
that triage situation and this has been
impressed upon me by many people to just
listen you you can take a minute here
and breathe and relax and I'm like yeah
but I got to do this and then this is
happening and it's like yeah five years
ago you had to be that way maybe two
years ago you had to be that way but now
you don't have to be that way and what
is it all worth if you can't really feel
gratitude moments a moment for what you
have co-created and to be present in
your own life and that's something that
I definitely struggle with moment to
moment and something that I want to be
able to embrace and bring into my life
in a more meaningful way and it's that's
a challenge for me you know because I'm
running I'm running this program and the
fear associated with flipping the switch
and doing it a different way gets
associated in my mind with
stopping you know like an arresting of
the things that got me here right like
this is the way I do it and this is
what's working to do it anyway
differently would mean risking capsizing
the whole thing mm-hmm well first of all
I want to say thank you that you have
done an extraordinary job of coming into
this level of expression and it's
absolutely beautiful to see and it's
breathtaking and that has been an
amazing experience for all of us
definitely I would also say again that
in a human format we like to make a list
and say from the brain that we have all
these things to do first and then we'll
get to the spirituality and so what we
have to remember and what I will remind
you is it is the purity of this
relationship that fruited this entire
drama the entire thing that we're doing
so it started on a very special day well
it started before but the day that we
actually were married it was a spiritual
world concert there were channelers
Bhagavad Das kirtan gospel singers
African wedding dancers and it literally
was all about spirituality and it was
one of the most beautiful days in my
life I posted it on our anniversary on
my Instagram feed that ceremony is what
was the intention that created what we
experienced now are you connected with
that yeah okay I am so what I'm saying
is that I just wanted to check in every
ass you're like yeah I was okay no it it
is that level of desire of devotion it's
really this devotion this this this love
affair with life the love affair with
the wonder of life and what is pulsing
through each one of us and all life and
so what I would say to you is that you
don't have to change the format of how
you run the podcast I mean sure you can
shift and all that and you know we're
going to be taking some time
in December which is magnificent so all
of that is great I guess what I'm
talking to more is in the day-to-day of
how you go about your day I know there
is time that is spent either in this for
all of us I'm not like judging I'm just
saying it's social media it's scrolling
through Twitter it's Netflix it's it's
stuff that we do out of habit stuff that
we do out of habit and this would be
good for everybody what if we all made a
list for the next week of things we do
out of habit that are not high
vibrational activities that are
furthering the life that are actually
met being medicated or being suppressed
or controlled by the society to check
out what we are serving as medication
yeah and but we just do it by default
because we don't really even we're not
really thinking of it we're like okay I
worked a hard day now I deserve an
episode of Han man's head made today
because I just want to distract myself
and I just want to breathe and just can
I just not think about my life right now
and invest in some story that all
that'll lull me into a sleep state but
what if you like chose let's not ask you
to give it all up let's just say if just
one day a week there was a two-hour time
period where you turned all the lights
off and turned on a candle and you
actually communed with the greater being
that you are and you were like you know
like when I sit in that it's like you
know lead me guide me direct me reveal
yourself to me like reveal the path to
me I'm here I'm here I'm listening I'm
listening so what I'm asking is what
would happen are in our relationship if
we used our beautiful intimacy our
divine sexual connection our wonderful a
parent play of opposites what if we
actually seeped that consciously in
devotion not from not just from my side
because all these years I've been
holding this I've been doing this the
countless ceremonies the countless
you know rituals that I've done for
years and years and years and years what
I'm saying is that we have an
opportunity to actually step into this
in the next level and it's a level of
visioning it's a level of taking
responsibility and it's a level of
saying okay we're available you've shown
us the divinity of art of our extremes
together in relationship and now we know
that it's a new time on planet Earth and
that we have an opportunity to move into
a new kind of relationship so lead us so
we're here we're here and we're
listening it doesn't have to be like a
big thing but it could just be that what
if that was devoted to us instead of you
going to group instead or maybe in
addition but it seems like again it's
like if this relationship just like
everything if it's always the last thing
because you think it's always going to
be to get be here then that's the danger
or that's the misstep because it's not
necessarily it's not nothing that is on
uncared-for unacknowledged or you know
not not given the energy then that thing
doesn't grow it doesn't change it
doesn't shift
[Music]